я запрошу і для презентації
харчування за англійську та мови та Тетяну
юріївну Бєляєв
патронів чити
а добро дня шинам миколай не я навіть рада
ще
мої чоловіки вісті розповіли про
програмі англійську новий як я їх
побачила ще й там навіть ті, кого
вапометала я мама трьох дітей
яко самого круто і вона шукала і
приватним способом я закінчила
університет шевченка топ, тобто.
диплом евоний викладок англійська
німецької move та своїх дітей вона в чаї
сама стіна я знаю ще
дуже багато людей я все за раз, як ви
знає англійську можу чини боїтеся
посилання в описі на дуже багато людей
скажіть але ми можемо написати
аліска за тином дуже важко і проблема
this але і близько жити в корені всіх
проблем на шию зв'язку
клуби і починаєш із дітьми
прощаюся розбавляти іноземну нову
дітям дуже терміново сказати і про себе ти
чого не знають про seba на сто відсотків
ще я люблю їсть і
Якою собою відпочиваю я був учора
cdma їжака з цим api малювання у просторі
потім а по дорозі і з ти ще травня буде
на сам перед викладати дітям старшого
класу в imovie про писання загальна
європейських стандартах навчання море та
ванни прописані в нашому державному
стандарті з чудського та усвяти
натиснули в програмах зінзі, тобто
заганяєш kill with сотня тема їжака
продукти харчування тема подорожника та
тільки в четвертому класі
від cd простіше did i might заспівав когось
раз побачити одного мало і хоче он
з аміту беру скажу чванливий дивани був
і топ та це треба вести
обов'язково як пріоритет чому ми не
можемо ввести там ще у програмі
пріоритет на жаль на судно роки на 35
хвалимо на тричі в 1 класі senso
зараз збір то я вашу маму про вибач
школи 1 роки на 35 хвали надією та
kenshi руку я таким а вас листи я
адже творю вати графічний образ слив
рейчел текстів я все розумію висоти
треба л.н. треба мати так вже пріоритети
там у про перший клас і нахабного світло
не шкіль
ми зарубав це кіпру позиції розум вилиці
маяка практично протияться у сфері
труби ти пив руку усний курс ція
цукровій школі так і в
спеціалізованих заколи
усний для вона ви че скарбничку ваня і
робила яєчної блискавки у програмі
великого класу не прописані такі
пробач промови хаваю уотсон і в петру
чайках ванни і вона, наприклад, підручний
по корпук
ось синім за зустрічається на 60 інших
туринці
відчепи таня яковенко я спитаю дня ось
синій ще тут такого ми ж навіщо за чаєм
у кліше окей
в іншому петруччо на pc за зустрічається
раніше і частину тихіше я навіть рада зачепити
ручних на чичева пропан його пропан про нього
вид усного курсу повністю усного
персик європу для дітей та газета та
спеціалізованих шкіл
пенсію лист скоро ти до написання
litter f pl шуму класики літр та тильки
шрифтом print script tag то іншого ним
літрами кідді ти бачату підручних біля річки
витворюють нормальним природним ченом і
ви краще не атаки хромистих
граматичних форм але все ж таки 4 клас
lfc штуки як present perfect
така форма воно дуже чикаго для
філологів all i wanna заразні вживається
у
його розмах не море рахунку
квітник за кладем я хочу моя колега
Наталя розповіла про
спати або покликання її закладу вона прошу
душі кори місто доброго дня шину
миколаєва
ви майже парить нам і модератором якщо
його не прості завдання вуст і свист рук
з допомагають автору в початкових програм
вийдуть і нагару та офісний продукт нібито
за задоволені учень вчитель iv батьки в
через алі громадський
по при пий свічки баталій і завданням
виправилася і назвала дружина абу волю
watching програма з англійської моди на
ітері і ми з милий персі нагадала
містером відмінні компетенції значить
скоро ти воші тапаємо чому порядку взагалі
та й таким чином річки годинами форми мису
пропливав і винести топ 5 класу а
стругова хлопець з 3 до 4 класу ми так
важливо було сили на формування фанатичні
компетенції там ще у програмі ну або
квіткові завдання з організації
правильні артикуляції англійських звуків
ми з вами шви і море та вийдемо а ви нього
ідеальне поєднання audi його її листи
на галявину і на обидва дискові ви хреста
не бачать без enchant в армії вак
заміни крем і складних для ти до
людині тексті для чату не я найбільше
дискусії у нас вилетіла з приводу
листи
ми з меншою ви могли до формування
останні компетенції надавлю еньші вас
місця такого виду діяльності як вид злодії
не графічну занедбаний літр рекомендую
вчили теорію вати графічний образ літр
з на підручного матеріалу
ягту паличок зустрічі чок а я все
спеціалізовані школі видиме
персі навантаження габен англійської йому
ви там і про на мою все-таки біт
варівати графічний образ литві олив цін
і на листі хук гумку та робота з
листом по ви на рік і оповідач у
формі гри процес моніторингу ради
vantage та не те новий на початкових
програм для нахабно справа як заслуга
ви я на періодично подалі
повтори не на мою думку щось ціле
процесію в роті було отримають і більше
фахівців та кіпру чуєте засвоїли
все-таки друк ви зі школи і заходь
ще раз вона малює програму на
везучий підручнику а намалюю ці виступи
проходячи про посвіти
губарьова чого на і двері приходиш на
виставку
наша програма зараз вона спрея я
формування комунікативної
компетентності алга програми в
адже програмі вечора все ще від
програми і проливали теж багата
автореф і не моя викладаємо формації та
в унісон топтати і людові прозвали над
програму і вони б хрестові свої
терміни його не входите до одиниць сили та
хотілося програмі читка
ваги сковував ася і фраз і речення
які взуття слові для заучування враховані і
на вигляд злодії мене чому діалогах і
монологах такої ж програми завищувалася
місці для творчості був і виходьте з
машини вас ти дуже потужний вас 3 клас
вчитель міг би і ширший ти і
граматичний матеріал та токсичний
матеріал